ось лист сили
цей лист Сьогодні ми реєструємо до
всього суду минулого разу ми звертались
до однієї суди судді яка прострочила
термін вже на 4 роки проведення розгляду
Зараз ми для всього суду з проханням
виконати закон який був прийнятий в
Верховній Раді я його доповідав в
Верховній раді Ми ж для Леонідом за це
голосували і цей закон дуже простий Він
вимагає не вимагає ніякої особливої
процедури просто церкви які мають центр
в Москві повинні називатися російськими
От і все тобто ніякої нічого такого
немає це ніяка не репресія проти церкви
ніяка не її заборона бо заборона то інші
закони є і оскільки Я особисто бачу що я
конечно хотів щоб цю церкву заборонили
але от з того що я бачу з цими процесами
Я розумію що цього Ну може при цьому
президенту не статися і мені дуже
хотілося щоб хоча би цей закон був
виконаний Я переконаний що після того як
люди зрозуміють ті хто цього не розумію
що це церква не українська російська то
є рейтинг в чотирьох відсотків впаде Ще
до двох і це прискорить процес закриття
цієї п'ятої колони цієї корпорації Росії
в Україні
дуже просто тому що п'ята колона подала
звернення до Конституційного Суду і це
би нічого це це би дало можливість
закону виконуватись конституційний суд
би розглядав але вони паралельно
звернулись до того суду який мав
половити Януковича Як ви знаєте це про
це багато писали під час вторгнення це
суд
Вовка який президент обіцяв заборонити
ще 1,5 роки тому але він прийняв рішення
про те що поки Конституційний Суд не
розгляне е цей закон не вступить в дію
таке дуже сумнівне рішення але воно
існує от Таким чином згода двох судів
одного конституційного чи може навіть
однієї просто студії яка затягує цей
процес із рішення отого суду
адміністративного вони присутні до того
що цей закон який був прийнятий рівно
чотири роки тому не як вступити в дію
останні події може цьому посприяти як
вважаєте
роль церкви фсбного патріархату всім
зрозуміло питання ролі нашого
Конституційного суду України в цій
історії ситуації чи наш конституційний
суд теж вважає що Пропаганда ФСБ має
поширюватися в Україні і в розумах
українців чи конституційний суд має
виконати 75 статтю закону про
Конституційний Суд не дуже чітко
вказаний граничний термін найбільше пів
року півроку це скільки я в
конституційного суду для розгляду
будь-якої справи цей конституційний суд
розглядає справу вже більше 4 років цим
став прямо порушуючи норму статті яка
регулює його діяльність Тому ці судді
Конституційного Суду це ж не абстрактна
якась організація там є 18 суддів
Конституційного Суду які мають прийняти
рішення згідно закону вони цього не
роблять тим самим Вони працюють на
користь російського агресора це стаття
11 Кримінального кодексу України
називається державна зрада ознаки і
принаймні вбачаються в тому що вони
відмовляються визначений законом спосіб
і термін прийняти рішення ми не
вимагаємо від них конкретного рішення
хоча в нашій заяві і в нашому зверненні
е наше бачення ролі церкви російського
патріархату там викладено ми вимагаємо
від Конституційного Суду законного
рішення визначені строки і стверджує що
відмовляючись виконувати в законні
терміни свої повноваження і обов'язки
Конституційний Суд сьогодні працює на
руку Російської Федерації Путіна скільки
депутатів там написано підписалися у
звернення чи в товщині є звернення до
Конституційного Суду не маєте
підписатись не менше 45 народних
депутатів воно було дано ще минулим
скликання українського парламенту от
один із авторів от людина яка за це
голосувала і ще необхідна кількість
народних депутатів восьмого скликання
але
суд терміни визначені законом 75 стаття
рішення не прийнято він не має права
затягувати це питання ми сьогодні тут
для того щоб показати ми б не забули про
те що про роль церкви Ми не забули про
роль Конституційного Суду в тому що він
відмовляється Приймати це рішення ми тут
для того щоб сказати ми вимагаємо
виконання конституційних суду закону про
конституційний суд і прийняття рішення
яке Він вже давно прострочений і ми
будемо приходити сюди зверненнями
українських громадян от цей лист був
лист перед цим будуть іще звернення і
листи до Конституційного Суду можливо не
лише до нього буде визначена роль
прокуратури яка очевидно має теж дати
оцінку діяльності суддів Конституційного
Суду ми не залишимо це питання без
нагляду ми вимагаємо від корупційного
суду виконувати закон нещодавно було
рішення РНБО яке зобов'язує парламент
парламент вірніше розглянути новий який
законопроект про заборону Церкви
Московського патріархату написати Його я
так розумію потрібно хоча ми знаємо що є
вже три законопроекти плюс мінкульт має
знову провести релігієзнавчий експертизу
Я дуже проста ситуація Кияни мають
можливість бачити як динамічно відбулося
зміни архітектурної форми лавра якого
орендує рпц безумовно згадані тези які
колеги зараз озвучили і ті хто блокували
це рішення вони є прихожанами все
п'ятого колони і сателіту фсбного
безумовно То про що ви говорите - це
дієвий механізми але для порівняння з
точки зору п'ятого президента Я хочу
нагадати що справу по томосу і справу як
вона звучала в межах кримінального
провадження розслідування міжконфесійної
ворожнечі Вона аж до сих пір актуальна
ця справа і санкції на противагу які
оголошені вони трошки менш дієві більше
того скажу з точки зору тих підписантів
які підписали і блокували рішення про
яке ми зараз говоримо з колегами яке
сьогодні пенсійний суд відмовляється
розглядати блокує тим чи іншим чином це
так само прихожани і список цих прихожан
є загальнодоступних прихожани рпц ми
розуміємо з вами Що це цілий комплекс
взаємодії різних підрозділів ФСБ в нашій
країні це те саме продовження гібридної
війни ці інструменти потрібно обрубати
як щупальця з Прута Московського
мовчанства з точки зору наявних
механізмів достатньо рішення мінкульту
рішення Кабміну Про розлив догоринди
згаданих змін які відбулися і
неузгоджені були відповідно на
державному українськими структурами з
точки зору того питання яке ви
озвучували тих динамічних розшуків
доказової бази про державну зраду і так
далі сателітних підрозділах рпц ми маємо
на підставі ефективну роботу СБУ за що
їм вдячні але цю роботу варто продовжити
виявлені паспорти де громадяни які
проживають на території України з
російським громадянством звідси виникає
проста дуже дуже це запитання і проста
істина якщо ви знайдені документи які
суперечать здоровому глузду із і по суті
суперечать такий істини яка є існує
давно як держава Україна то можливо
варто вже прийняти висновки зовсім
іншого ґатунку і прийняти відповідні
рішення Як то що стосується прокуратури
як хтось стосується підрозділів які
відповідає за безпеку України одного
рішення РНБО яке носить проміжний
характер Недостатньо тому наша партійна
сила Карпатська Солідарність рухається
не тільки наскільки інтенсивно ми
рухаємося в правовому полі свого часу ми
отримали як Україна томос і цей томос
Він є дороговказом для всього
цивілізованого світу ми маємо рухатися
згідно і нього є одна назва української
православної церкви яка називається
православна церква України відповідно
виходячись вже параметрів ми ніхто тут
уже не сумнівається в Україні в
теперішньому часі що основний фундамент
української держави як себе не звучало
дивно для когось із п'яти з п'ятої було
це відповідно Віра мова і армії і
сьогодні армія на першому місці але це
не знімає питання віри тому що ми з
Вірою живемо в нашу державу і в Бога оп
оце от що ви можете їм відповісти Ми
сьогодні відповідаємо спільно з вами ми
притягуємо увагу державного органів про
те що ми говоримо про закони спосіб Ми
не говоримо про речі коли збиваються
просто вивіски ми говоримо не просто
проти номінацію ми говоримо про те що
потрібно зсередини змінити повністю
обставини Ми не говоримо про те що треба
тих людей які сьогодні є служителями
Бога які готові перейти до Української
церкви реальної державної яка про
державну міську політику підтримує яке
підтримує воїнів з 14-го року починаючих
їм дорога і і двері відчинені до церкви
яка українська пцу давайте ще одну зразу
скажу і ми йдемо бо там тоже значить
дивіться багато хто питає чому це не
було зроблено раніше до томоса це
зробити Було неможливо тому що до того
як був отриманий Порошенком і
української церквою після об'єднавчого
синоду Томас церква була легітимною на
території України і канонічною що
важливо для атеїстів чи не вірян
православ'я Це не має значення Але для
самої православної церкви канонічність
церкви має значення от вона була
остаточно втрачена під час передачі нам
Томаса і це Ну там можна називати різні
дати але остаточно це шостого січня
19-го року до цього е-е говорити про те
що Ця церква є незаконною з точки зору
релігії чи вона має бути перейменована
було некоректно тільки тому закон був
прийнятий тоді коли очевидно стало що
наступила нова реальність Отже коли
пройшов колеги говорили тому сам момент
перейменування і був проголосований тоді
а не раніше і він би вже ну діяв якби
ситуація в країні була інакше він може
давнодіви вони були не були оцієї
биоблудної назви але на жаль як Є так Є
Давайте ми сходимо про
підхожуватися на тому колеги і закликати
суспільство громадянське українське
яка сьогодні зареєстрована
Ростислава Павленко яка говорить про те
щоби інтенсивніше розглядалося питання
як невідкладне дійшло до зали Верховної
Ради це проект закону 8221 про заборону
рпц в Україні це закономірно в
теперішньому часі і коли як на зараз
Дякую